can you think back to one of your first
scripts and when you look at now where
you are and having critique people's
work and rewritten it and all the things
that you've done in your career what was
wrong with your first script I had the
chronic problem that ends the whole
reason I created my method the whole
thing that is behind the nutshell
technique I wrote so everybody thinks
they've got a great idea right for a
movie they don't what everyone what you
might have is the great idea for one you
don't have a story though you have what
I would call a situation and and it and
I would identify that as in my work as a
script consultant 99% of the time that's
what writers are writing they're failing
to write a story instead they're
creating a situation life is the
situation right life is this happens
then this happens then this happens then
this happens
that's not a story story is this happens
which leads to that happening which
makes it ironic when this other thing
happens there's this connection between
the parts and that's the problem I'm
seeing in 99% of writers that they are
creating a situation not a story and
that was exactly my problem I had a
great I thought a great idea who this
would make a great movie
and I couldn't understand why I was
feeling so blocked and having a hard
time writing it I thought it was me I
thought it was I must not be a good
enough writer or I must not be talented
enough no the problem well that might be
true too but the other problem was I
didn't have technique basically and
technique to understand the difference
between what a situation is and what a
story is so if you just have a situation
you're going to be laboring to get from
moment to moment to moment and and
there's not going to be a natural
connection and a natural progression and
so it's gonna feel stilted it's gonna
feel unnatural it's gonna feel like bad
writing
but with technique that's that's the
secret to making something feel like an
organic story that has has resonance and
has power it's not just reading
somebody's diary of unconnected events
these different events that happened to
somebody there's there's a glue that is
existing behind them that makes them the
coherent so I absolutely suffered from
the exact same problem that I've been
addressing that's the whole reason I
created my method to remember where you
were or what was going on when you sort
of had that aha moment about that in
terms of like was something did you
board you watch him something and I was
getting kind of a similar note to the
one I described that people were saying
things like they were using different
words but they were saying essentially
this isn't really a story it's a
situation the only thing was no one
could explain to me the difference and
so I had a sense of what the difference
was I had good training I had studied at
Columbia University I'd also studied
with some private screenwriting programs
in New York City and I learned a lot of
good things in these different programs
but no one was bringing it all together
and I could sense in this note I knew
there was truth in what I was hearing
even though no one could explain to me
how to transform it I got what they were
saying and I had a sense that they're
sort of if I make a huge generalization
to approaches out there one is a linear
approach a strictly three-act structure
you know beat method kind of approach to
screenwriting and the other is a more
character based character arc approach
the problem I was having and the problem
that 99% of writers are having I could
tell belonged somewhere in the
intersection between these methods that
these methods do not exist if a story is
functioning properly these are not
separate things character arc in three
acts story structure there are actually
very specific points
where they need to intersect and if you
fail to hit those intersections you're
going to end up with a situation but not
a story and so with this note I was
getting I started analyzing movies I
started deconstructing movies and you
know you constructed hundreds of them
just kind of obsessively taking notes
and trying to find these moments and it
took a little while and right off the
bat I can identify I essentially
identify eight elements that are
required to tell the story and my method
and that and these are interconnected
elements these are not beats these are
not moments in time these are elements
of the story and I'd say right off the
bat I knew what five of them were but it
took a little while of analyzing movies
and then it did happen that was kind of
this breakthrough moment on the last
like last movie that I deconstructed in
this period where I was like boom the
eighth method I was like oh my god this
actually works I can't believe it
what movie was you know I I don't know
that I can identify the movie I have
notebooks full of them at that time but
it was kind of like holy cow this
actually works once at once that last
one dropped and then I I could use those
eight things and apply it up against
every movie from then on it was like oh
my god they're there they're there I
can't believe it it's there in every
single movie when you go into several
movies in your book yeah I do
mm-hmm right from Chinatown to silver
linings playbook just you run the gamut
yeah I made a point of doing that so the
book and I'll show you back yeah
beautiful cover much yeah thank you so
it's a nice lovely large format book and
I'd recommend people get the paperback
not the kindle for that reason okay
because it's a just a beautifully
designed large format book and one of
the big features of the book is the last
section I have in it 30 different Oh
movies that's great so it's all in my
one nutshell form you want to form 30
different movies and so the books are
designed for you to flip back and forth
when you're reading and I I mention a
movie so that you can look and see how
it fits in the
in the alphabet alphabetical listing a
book of movies in the back you can see
how that element fits into the whole
picture so yeah I have everything you
know in the back from Casablanca to pulp
fiction to August Osage County write
movies that are different time periods
different genres movies you probably
think had almost nothing in common
structure-wise other than maybe three
acts maybe I can identify these eight
elements and all of these different
lines so I just wanted to illustrate
that this is not a formulaic you know
it's not formula right we're talking
about very very different movies that
are not following one template no one
would say the template to pulp fiction
in Casablanca or anything alike right
but underlying it they have at the very
basis they have the same structural
elements that we're looking at and that
are required for making them the great
movies that they are they're the same
eight things going on sorry to interrupt
but I you can e-mail is that right if
someone would like a graph yes so my
next shelf form so this is the central
tenets of my method is my natural
technique form basically I drew up these
eight elements that are required to tell
a story on and put it on a one-page form
for my clients and my students and
rather glibly wrote on the first one
screenplay is in a nutshell and that's
how the name was born it's great fun
yeah and so this form I can use so it's
a visual method so we can look we can
see right on the piece of paper what's
working in knots working not working and
yes anyone can download it my website
Jill Chamberlin calm you can download
free versions of the these worksheets
for your own use
great um so you can take that Y at a
nutshell technique and start playing
around with it start using it for your
own stories so this away and what's
important I want to emphasize it's not
just it's different than the B cheat
methods these are not beats in time
they're four of these are moments in
time the rest of them are and what's
really different is the inner
connection between the parts I don't
know any other method in the 3000 books
on screenwriting than on Amazon none of
the other ones that I'm aware of
explains the connection to between the
parts most of the books you're gonna
find on Amazon that deal with structure
they do what I call a beat sheet method
where they tell you you're supposed to
hit these pre prescribed fifteen or
twenty two or however many beats that
happen in a typical Hollywood movie I'm
throwing all that out these are not
moments in time of have been a first
scene al a scene you know identifying
things like that these are other
structural elements to the story other
than moments in time what's important is
the connection between the parts the
glue that's going to hold them together
I'm wondering what a movie looks like
when it's just a bunch of situations
strung together yeah so how does that
look let's suppose a screenwriters done
that they haven't fixed it now the films
out there what does that look like
it feels so it feels episodic that's
another way to put it where it's kind of
one moment after a moment where each
it's almost like we're seeing separate
short films struck strung together
instead of one coherent story and by the
way not every movie tells a story I'm
talking about movies that tell a story
actually some of the films of Richard
Linklater famously you know he and he
has said this quite a bit that the
movies like slacker and boyhood are
great movies they're not telling a story
though right in in right it's not one
coherent story it's looking at a slice
of life it's looking at different
following a character there might be
some things the matically pulling it
pulling them in common but it's not a
story
social slacker yeah yeah so it's it's
it's not a not every movie tells the
story I have to say though it's
extremely rare to find a movie in
theaters that doesn't tell a story
that's you know it's pretty unusual so
that you know that the Richard Linklater
is the exception of to the rule where we
see something that's successful that we
can be moved by
that actually isn't telling a story the
vast majority of the time movies need to
tell a story for us to feel satisfied
we're gonna get restless it's gonna feel
episodic we're gonna get lost on
tangents why are we following this
character what did that moment have to
do with that moment they're going to be
things that happen that where you're
setting plants but you're not paying off
so and it's a chronic problem that I see
in screenwriters that they are failing
to tell a story
you